اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم اقدم اليكم مقابله خاصه من اسطنبول
مع اكنيور رئيسه حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
الكرديه في اسطنبول والمرشحه لعضويه
البرلمان التركي في انتخابات 20 23 اهلا
بك معنا استاذه نور في مقابله خاصه على
العربيه
شكرا جزيلا
ابدا وصوره عبد الله اوجلان خلفنا
بالعلاقه مع حزب العمال الكردستاني ندخل
في ظل بالموضوع مباشره نحن في الاعلام
العربي عندما نتحدث عنكم نقول الذي يعتبر
الجناح السياسي لحزب العمال الكردستاني
انتم ماذا تقولون علما ان الحزب مصنف
ارهابيا وزعيم مسجون
من كونه ونقعد يشتري عن حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه حزب يشكل الاكراد واغلبيته
ولا شك انه يولي اهتماما كبيرا للسيد عبد
الله اوجلان وكل من يمارس السياسه يعلم
بانه سيكون لاجلان دور محوري وتاثير كبير
في حل المساله الكرديه غير ان حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي اي حزب الخضره اليساري باسمه
الحالي حزب تركي يتكون من الاتراك
والاكراد والاشتراكيين والعلويين والسنه
ونحن لسنا بجناح سياسي لاجلان نحن حزب
سياسي ديمقراطي تركي مستقل لديه برنامج
سياسي يطالب بنظام ديمقراطي والمساوات
للجميع
ولكن الحكومه التركيه تصنف حزب العمال
الكردستاني ارهابيا والحكومه التركيه تمثل
الشعب تاتي على اثر انتخابات
برلمانيه ورئاسيه وبالتالي انتم تعارضون
اراده الشعب التركي في ذلك اليس كذلك
نحن نعلم بان الاكراد والشعب الكردي في
تركيا ومنطقه الشرق الاوسط القريبه
يناضلون للحفاظ على هويتهم وحقهم في
البقاء ونرى ان حل المساله الكرديه سواء
في تركيا او في الجغرافيا القريبه سيكون
ذات مخزن اذا تم بالوسائل والاساليب
الديمقراطيه والمفاوضات مع مخاطبها
الحقيقيين يعني مع المؤسسات التي تدافع عن
حقوق الاكراد والان تتبع الحكومه التركيه
سياسه الصراع في حل المساله الكرديه
للحفاظ على سلطتها وصونها ونحن نرى ان هذا
النهجه ليس بصحيح والسبيل الصحيح انما
يكمن في الاسلوب الديمقراطي والسلمي وهو
من سياخذ بايدينا الى الايام الجميله
وليست السياسه لذلك لا نتحدث بنفس
المفاهيم نحن نرى المساله الكرديه مساله
واقعيه ينبغي الاقدام على خطوات لحلها
الاكراد موجودون في تركيا والشرق الاوسط
ذلك الشعب الكردي نحن نقول بضروره ان
يعيشوا في تلك البلدان في ظل نظام
ديمقراطي استقلالي قائم على المساواه وان
يكون الاكراد هم من يقررون ذلك ونرفض وصف
الحكومات لحزب العمال الكردستاني بانه
تنظيم ارهابي ولا نقر به هنا اريد ان
اذكركم بان مفهوم الارهاب والارهابيين في
هذه الجغرافيا انما استعملت بوصفها سياسه
صدرت من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اتذكرون عقب الهجمات على برجي التجاره
العالميه في الحادي عشر من سبتمبر قامت
اداره بوش بتصدير مفهوم سياسيا الى العالم
فوسم كل من يناهض الانظمه والسلطات بوسم
الارهاب تحت مسمى مفهوم الامن الوقائي ولا
يمكن لاي قضيه ان تحل بهذه الطريقه ولا
يمكن للقضيه الكرديه ان تحل بهذه المفاهيم
نحن مع الديمقراطيه والعداله والمساواه
اضافه الى عبد الله اوجلان في الصوره هناك
احد قياداتكم كبيره في السجن وهو صلاح
دمرداش وكان مرشح في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
السابقه من السجن ولكن هذه المره اختار
الحزب الارشح احدا ومن ثم دعمتهم كمال
كريتش اولا لماذا لم تختاروا اسما خاصا
بكم للرئاسه
نحن نطالب بتغيير النظام في تركيا لا
تغيير شخص واحد فقط بل تغيير النظام برمته
بلى تخلينا عن طرح مرشح للرئاسه واتخذنا
هذا القرار بعد الزلزال لان دعم اي ممثل
قوي يمتلك قوه تغيير النظام حيل اردوغان
من شانه ان يزيد فرص تغيير النظام كان
قرارنا قرارا استراتيجيا وما دعمنا لكمالك
الا لتغيير نظام اردوغان ونظام القصر
والتحول الى الخطوه الاولى نحو نظام
ديمقراطيتش
هل صحيح انها مقابل ذلك
وعدكم بحزمه وعود لينفذها اندعم ان
دعمتموه للرئاسه
وما هي خير
مطابقه لا يوجد بيننا اي تفاهم مكتوب لقد
صرحنا بارائنا من قبل الراي العام نطالب
بنظام ديمقراطي لتركيا والقضاء على الفقر
وحل المساله الكرديه والعداله نحن لا
نساوم احدا ونحن من سنحقق ذلك لكن لابد من
تمهيد الطريق لذلك وتغيير النظام ولا شيء
بين ايدينا لا تفاهم مع اي شخص وراء
الكواليس لقد قلنا ما نهدف اليها امام
الجماهير والراي العام وبكل صراحه وشفافيه
وسنواصل ذلك
ولكن يعني هو يقول انه سيطلق صراح صلاح
الدين دبرتاش
وعثمان كضاله ايضا المتهم بالتوارث
بانقلاب او محاوله انقلاب 2016
ويقال ايضا بانه من الوعود التي قدمت
اليكم حل القضيه الكرديه وانه وقع من
المعلومات غير المؤكده انه وقع لكم على
ورقه
بانه سينفذ هذه الوعود لكم ان دعمتموه
للرئاسه حيث
لا لا يوجد شيء من هذا القبيل ينبغي اطلاق
سراح صلاح الدين دمرداش وعثمان كافالا لان
محاكم حقوق الانسان الاوروبيه بما في ذلك
المحاكم التركيه اتخذت قرارات عده بشان
اخلاء سبيل صلاح الدين دمرداش وكفاله من
السجن فلو تم تنفيذ القانون لاخليه
سبيلهما ولا يلزم احد بتقديم اي تعهد لنا
في ذلك ولا صحه لاي خبر في نريد ان يعلم
ذلك نحن نرى انه ان تم رفع ضغوط اردوغان
عن القانون فستكون النتائج وفق القانون
حتما قلت لنا اتخذتم قرارا استراتيجيا في
الحزب بدعمه دون اي وعود اي قرار
استراتيجي يمكن لحزب
بوزنكم الحالي الشعبي والبرلماني اي قرار
استراتيجي يمكن ان اتخذه بدون ان يتلقى
ضمانات او وعود خاصه وان قضيتكم شائكه
ومعقده مع الدوله التركيه
بذلك وصلنا الى ايامنا هذه وسندخل
البرلمان في هذه الانتخابات باسم حزب
الخضر اليساري وبفضل ثقه لنسبه اعضائنا في
البرلمان وتازره مع الشعب والنضال
الديمقراطي سينفتح باب التغيير في تركيا
نحن لا نمارس السياسه تكالا على الاشخاص
ولا على وعودهم نحن نثق
وببرنامجنا وسياساتنا تركيا اليوم على
مشارف التغيير تركيا ستتغير سيتغير النظام
والبيئه السياسيه وسيجلب ذلك الليونه
والانشراح والسلم الى ربوع تركيا والشرق
الاوسط وكذلك في علاقاتنا مع اوروبا
والعالم نحن لا نثق الا بانفسنا ولا حاجه
لنا الى التفاهمات والاتفاقيات وسنبقى
معارضين لاي خطا يصدر من اي لاعب سياسيه
فبرنامجنا واضح وصريح وكذلك اقوالنا
وسنبقى نواصل مطالبنا في الديمقراطيه
ونضالنا من اجلها سواء في البرلمان او في
الحياه الاجتماعيه وسنواصل نضالنا من اجل
هذا الشعب
ولكنكم تدعمون قياديا في حزب الشعب
الجمهوري هل نسي حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
الكردي العمليات العسكريه التي كنتم
تسمونها بالمجازر التي خاضها حزب الشعب
الجمهوري عندما كان يسيطر على السلطه
ومنها مصدر الدرسين
نحن لا ندعم حزب الشعب الجمهوري بل ندعم
ترشح كمالك لصدار اوغلو للرئاسه هذان
امران مختلفان ولا نتخذ البرنامج السياسي
لتحالف الامه مرجعيه لنا بل نتخذ برنامجنا
السياسي مرجعيه طبعا لم ننسى مجزره درسيم
وزيلان وكذلك مجزره روبوسكي والمجازر
الاخرى وها هي الصفحه السوداء لتاريخ
تركيا الجمهوريه تتم مئويتها الاولى وتتجه
الى المئويه الثانيه نقول ونحن نتجه الى
المئويه الثانيه بضروره مواجهه هذا
التاريخ الاسود ونخلق دوله لا ترتكب فيها
امثال هذه المجازر ولاجل ذلك لنتكل على
احد بل على الشعب وانفسنا نحن لسنا بحزب
صغير نحن حزب التغيير في الوقت ذاته ونقول
للمجتمع التركي والشعب الكردي والاصحاب
العقائد من المسلمين والعلويين والسنه
والارمن النصارى لا يمكن الباس قميصا ذي
لون واحد لهذا البلد نحن بحاجه الى نظام
تعددي سلمي يعانق الالوان كلها ونحن عنوان
ذلك اي حزب الشعب الديمقراطي باسمه القديم
وحزب الخضر اليسري باسمه الجديد نحن حزب
لا يثق الا ببرنامجه ونضاله واضيف هناك
الاف من السياسيين الاكراد يقبعون في
السجون بسبب هذا النظام الحاكم وبالتالي
ينبغي لهذا النظام ان يتغير تركيا ستتغير
وسننطلق بمسيرتنا لاجل مجتمع مستقر وهادئ
لا مجتمع خائف وفقير يهدد بالحرب وقطعا
سيبدا التغيير
يبدو ان البعض يشير الى ان مشاركتكم في
دعم كليتش دار اوغلو قد تبعد عنه بعض
القوميين مثل جماعه ميرال اكشنر او حتى
بعض القوميين في حزب الشعب الجمهوري نفسه
الى اي مدى تعتقدين بان هذا صحيح وانكم
درستم ذلك بالفعل يبدو وفق بعض المؤشرات
ان حزب العداله والتنميه يراهن على ذلك
الان
بالاتفاق
في الواقع لدينا تحالف وهو تحالف العمل
والحريه وهناك تحالف الامه يجمع
الكرام لاوجلو
تحالفنا مختلف اتخذنا قرارا بدعمك
ولسنا جزءا من تحالف الامه نحن نمارس
السياسه ونرى استراتيجيه بارادتنا الحره
والمستقله اما التحالف الثاني تحالف الامه
فشان
نحن اتخذنا قرارا استراتيجيا لصالح تركيا
ولم نسال احدا ولم نفكر ان كانوا يقرون
بذلك ام لا وهذا هو الصحيح وسننفذ هذا
القرار الذي اتخذناه ينبغي للسياسيين في
تركيا ان يكونوا شجعانا وهذا ما نقوله
للجميع ينبغي ان يكونوا شجعانا لحل قضايا
تركيا عليهم ان يكونوا صرحاء في حل القضيه
الكرديه دون اللجوء الى صراع وعلى الجميع
ان يقبل بالحل السلمي وبوسائل ديمقراطيه
في البرلمان وفي جميع مجالات المجتمع وان
تدخل تركيا في مسار افضل فشعبنا تعب تعب
من الفقر ومن الحرب والصراع المتواصل في
هذا بلد الجنه في هذا البلد اتراكم واكراد
وعرب وسريان وعلويون وارمن على الجميع ان
يتقبل هذه الحقيقه ويطور نظاما قانونيا
ومفهوما وفق ذلك على هذه البلاد ان تفتح
هذه الابواب وتبني حياه اجتماعيه افضل
التغيير على الابواب وعندما يتحقق هذا
التغيير سيعود خيره على الجميع
حركزه في عيد
تحدثت عن تحالفكم الخاص وهو تحالف العمل
والحريه المرشح طبعا بقوه الى البرلمان في
البرلمان السابق لديكم 11 فصل سبعه بالمئه
من هذا البرلمان يعني الى ما تطمحون في
البرلمان الجديد في انتخابات 20 23 ما هي
حساباتكم كم مقعد او كم النسبه في داخل
البرلمان
تركيا مجلس
البرلمان التركي يضم 600 نائب ويتكون من
تحالف الجمهور وتحالف الامه وتحالف العمل
والحريه ونحن نريد ان ندخل البرلمان ب 100
نائبه لاننا سنكون في دور محوري وسنكون
قوه رئيسه تنفذ ما نقوله وتدفع تركيا الى
التغيير اذا انتم تطمحون الى نحو 33 مقعدا
اضافيا عن المقاعد الحاليه التي تملكونها
اردوغان الم يعزز
حقوق الكرديه كما يقول الاعلام العالمي
قبل المتعاطف معه الم يمنح حقوقا في اللغه
وممارسه الشعائر والتقاليد والاحتفالات ما
لم يفعله معكم اي رئيس في السابق لماذا لا
تعزون الفضل له في هذا الاطار بل تستمرون
في معارضته وتريدون اسقاطه حاليا عندي ما
هي الحقوق التي منحها ان ممارسه الشعب
للغه ورفع الضغوط عنها ليس بمنح بحق هناك
نحو 30 مليون كرديه ينبغي ان نسال اردوغان
الذي يتبجح بانه منح الاكراد حقها ممارسه
لغتهم انه ينزل اللوحات المكتوبه باللغه
الكرديه تلك اللوحات التي سمح بها في فتره
الحل السلميه يزج بالسياسيين الاكراد
بالسجون وكل من يمكن ان يمثل الاكراد يقبع
في السجون اردوغان ينظر الى الكردي الذي
يقف معه يؤيده نظره حسنه ويصف الكردي الذي
يطالب بالحريه بالارهابيه ما هي الحقوق
التي منحها انظروا الى قناه الكرديه التي
يسمونها
تابعوها نصف ساعه وسيتبين اهي حق ام ظلم
ويرى الظلم الممارسه على الاكراد المناسبا
ويرى قسما من الاكراد ارهابيين يدعي منحى
الاكراد حقهم عبر ضرب الاكراد ببعضهم
وضعوا قيما في جميع بلدياتنا ما هي الحقوق
التي منحها الشعب يختار رؤساء بلدياتهم ثم
ياتون ويعزلونهم ويضعون قيما مكانهم دون
اصدار اي قرار من المحاكم هناك عشره
الالاف من السياسيين الاكراد يقبعون في
السجون ومثلهم في المنفى في اوروبا والشرق
الاوسط عن اي حق يتحدث واي حقا يمكن ان
يكون اكثر طبيعيه من ممارسه الانسان للغته
الامه وهذا الحق ليس بمنه ولا شيء هناك من
الاقرار الاراده السياسيه للاكراد
والتعديلات تمنح الاكراد حق المساواه وحق
الاكراد في التعليم بلغتهم وينظرون الى
هذه الامور على انها فعاليات ونشاطات
ارهابيه ما هي الحقوق التي منحها اردوغان
للاكراد وان كان هناك حق منح للاكراد
فانما حصلوا عليه بفضل نضالهم وليس بمنه
من احد قدموا تضحيات كبيره من اجل نيله
ولا يزالون يقدمون الحق لا يمنح بمنه من
الاشخاص ولا يوجد مثيل لذلك في التاريخ
استاذه حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي في
اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لوجودك معنا في هذه
المقابله الخاصه على شاشه العربيه
اشكركم ايضا ينبغي ان يسود العالم العربي
الامن والامان والهدوء وجميع الشعوب التي
تتابع قناتكم العربيه والجغرافيا التي
نعيش فيها نحن لا نستحق الحياه السيئه
والصراع والامور التي تخرجنا من الانسانيه
نحن شعوب حره نعيش بكرامه ومرفوع الراس
على ثقه بان هذه الانتخابات ستفتح لنا
ابواب التغيير واتمنى لشعوب الشرق الاوسط
ان تستخرج لنفسها حظا من هذا النصر الذي
سنحرزه وحي الجميع
ونحن نتمنى ذلك ايضا شكرا جزيلا مره جديد
لوجودك معنا مشاهدينا الكرام هكذا نكون
اذا قد وصلنا الى ختام هذه الحلقه هذه
المقابله الخاصه من اسطنبول مع رئيسه حزب
شعوب الديمقراطي الكردي في اسطنبول نور
والمرشحه للانتخابات البرلمانيه التركيه
في انتخابات 2023 شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات